hey guys i'm ryan right I am jevi Jabby
here my broseph Joseph from the same MO
civ here we go we're gonna check out the
trailer for kill your friends the
biographical story of javi coy it's
alright it's a Nicholas Hoult film and
Ed screech that like whole imagine
you're standing on wafer thin ice
beneath your feet you can see sharks
circling these are your colleagues your
friends you're smart nicely sharp wishes
back off welcome to the music industry
great nice I'm on the wrong
one thing matters in this racket big hit
records never after thinking about yeah
like a [ __ ] 20 far how far are you
willing to go they're all going to take
in a band like Supergirl oh Jesus what
Oh
you wouldn't last ten minutes
alright so that's like that was that
poster you have that make it a bit
psycho no not psycho what's his name
Christian Bale American side american
psycho yeah yeah that's what I reminds
me of that seemed like two totally
different movies and what efforts yeah
no I agree with you but it has that kind
of feel to it where it's setting up this
world that's very pompous and people
think very highly of themselves and then
he just loses it and decides to start
killing them that's Americans like thank
you yeah I could definitely see that and
the way the portrayal is going down
nicholas hoult is not doing Patrick
Bateman you know I'm Nicholas Hoult one
of those actors that the more I see him
films the awesomer he gets like what
else has he done I don't know if Yuri
road that's right I was like I know his
face from somewhere but I don't know
where a note from I love fury road ya
know he's and he was the scene stealer
for me in that movie man I thought he
was fantastic I think he just grows
tired of their attitude in their nature
and he's sickened by it that's the most
i can gather from i'm like why else
would he start killing them I just
wonder if it'll make a smooth tonal
transition you got like okay it's kind
of like that wolf of Wall Street Music
living it up in the entertainment
industry were yeah and then all of a
sudden it takes this other twist to it
which I like but I feel like that won't
happen to like halfway through the film
and I wonder if it'll actually feel like
it belongs in some dozen type of
American Psycho though American Psycho
they show pretty early on that he's a
psychopath and he you know it kills a
homeless guy should I don't know man I
just remembered the scene with him
[ __ ] those two girls and he's like
looking at his muscles in the mirror
yeah that was based on my biography the
trailer wasn't edited that well though
it kind of out of nowhere comes into
this element where he's a killer that's
how it blends out of me a little bit
that's what i mean by the tonal shift at
this movie might convey mean it is just
a trailer I know these are just my
trailer concerns right from watching it
right I'll watch it just for Nicholas
Hoult yeah um yes I agree it's a satire
in the music industry just like just
like American Psycho was a satire in the
80s yeah you know I get it american
psycho I understand nobody but why now
why is this fit and film coming out now
what what is so particular about the
music industry that it warrants this
film I don't know
a good question actually because there's
a movie coming out this weekend called
we are your friends which is also about
the music industry Zac Efron movie where
is a DJ it all happens at once yeah
american psycho really is the big theme
of this movie for sure it's like british
psycho english psycho vs UK UK psycho
london psycho london psycho london
psycho that's pretty much what this fake
stuff that doesn't look like London it
looks like it looks like New York well
they're probably traveling a lot in this
movie ok you know it's the music biz you
know how it can be I know it looks like
it could be a fun cult movie anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the Chanel if
you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out Jabby
kawai on the jab EK channels evan is or
go to youtube page com youtube page calm
jab eco a where there's also reactions
on there wouldn't you know and short
films and other fun shindigs i bought
that URL you did youtube page calm you
really bought that your go click on it
right now YouTube page calm that wasn't
just some that's not a joke joke you
were making that was like a legit thing
yeah youtube page Wow and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
and periscope because if we get enough
followers you know what screw the proper
placement drugs to a shout-out haven't
done one of those
not TV dad victor ramirez guys this is
my first request i think LOL he sent us
a youtube video funniest laughing news
blue man sounds kind of fun to watch
actually keep on kicking ass shoutout
I've been shouted outed anyway thanks
you guys make my day everyday I got a
question what why aren't most of these
subscribers like literal like a lot of
them just don't know how to type a
literal like illiterate the literal the
literals the work is it a word is Navy
that's not a word illiterate and now the
word you're the roller I'm try to make a
point here that they're the literal see
is bad don't make me look dumb is the
syntax that you're talking about let's
see what you look like buddy okay okay
wow wow okay you have a photo here can't
show it because there's a girl in the
photo but you have your tongue out and
you have a crucifix around your neck I'm
telling you right now if you have a
crucifix around her neck this is a major
sin what you are doing with this girl
you are suggesting oral fellatio with
this woman by sticking your tongue out
she looks like she is down for it is
that a good representation of being a
Catholic my friend I think he just wants
a little teapot you want something
popping on in me and in this photo you
look like a straight-up serial killer
you're not gonna show these to the
audience I'll show the serial killer one
there you guys go